my name is
the people call me
oda
[Music]
i live in the center of oklahoma delta
it's wonderful
[Music]
delta is protected
and people in botswana can benefit from
a conservation-based tourism economy
[Music]
mr water belongs to one of many
communities who rely on the water that
begins thousands of kilometers north in
angola
but upstream local people don't benefit
from the same sustainable livelihoods
elephants the lions
[Music]
like mr water elias lives from what the
okavango basin provides
but overhunting
deforestation
and unchecked commercial agriculture are
putting the source waters of the delta
at risk leaving not only elias's
livelihood at stake but also a million
other people living across angola
namibia and botswana
milivesic
event
working with elias mr water
and many others across the region
national geographic and de beers through
their ocavango eternal partnership will
support community-based conservation
and help ensure that land is protected
cooperatives
local community training and support for
sustainable agriculture and small
business development all contribute to
local communities prospering in harmony
with nature
as their stewardship safeguards the
future of the entire ocavango system